today we're going to be speaking with
janis varufakas who is the former
finance minister of greece professor of
economics at the university of athens
co-founder of the international
grassroots movement and also author of
several several books including most
recently another now
dispatches from an alternative present
uh great to have you today i appreciate
it
thank you david thank you so to start
with um the the current pandemic we've
seen a number of different
aspects of the global economy exposed by
the pandemic including the fragility of
supply chains
the fragility of the sort of social
welfare apparatus in many different
countries when employees get sick and
can't come to work
we've seen the world's debt increase
significantly
when you think about the last two years
and the pandemic's effect on the global
economy what are your big concerns and
takeaways
well there are many
changes and disasters
at the quantitative
level so things that were already bad
got much much worse so if you were a
precariously employed worker
your life became
even more miserable than it was
within our countries and between our
countries inequalities have skyrocketed
but that's a quantitative effect
we had these problems before they've
been magnified if you think about it the
crisis which begun in wall street in
2008
and caused the fed the european central
bank the central banks of the world
to band together
and start printing mountain ranges of
money
in order to support financial sectors
that what happened effectively in the
first
semester of 2009 under obama gordon
brown in england and so on
was effectively
states central banks replaced private
profit in order to float the financial
sector that caused huge inequalities
those who were in the money markets
never had it so good those who were not
um
suffered suffered the permanent
stagnation the kobe 19 exacerbated that
turbocharged that
but
we are now in the process
of another major shock to the system
which is a qualitative shock because
between 2009 and 2020 the central banks
have been stabilizing
the financial markets
in the way that they just described
in the way that we're all familiar with
but now
they are
between
a rock and a hard place the central
banks why because
they have zombified states
and corporations so
my the my country the government of my
country is completely zombified it's
totally bankrupt and relies on the
central bank of europe to keep printing
money to keep it afloat to a large
extent you could even say that
to a lesser extent but to a large extent
about the federal government united
states
your debt relies to a very large extent
on the fed's capacity and willingness to
continue to
roll it over
same in england the same thing in japan
to a large extent
but
because of the disruption of the supply
chains that you mentioned
and the fact that we now have serious
cost push inflation cost push inflation
not the bond pool cost push inflation
that is putting them in
in a dumped if they do dumped if they
don't situation central banks if they
continue to refloat the financial
markets are going to be fueling
inflation
which is creating significant political
and social problems
if they stop doing that then
corporations and states that rely on
this
extending and pretending of their dead
are going to go under
and this is going to be the qualitative
effect that we are going to be
remembering in 10 20 years
time
regarding this period this juncture so
in the united states and in other
countries when you talk about deficit
spending sometimes there's two very
different views you have people on one
side who say deficit spending is is
always bad you have people on the other
side who sometimes say deficit spending
doesn't really matter if you never have
to pay it back and sometimes there's a
more balanced view or it sounds balanced
which is
deficit spending can be okay
if it's on economically stimulative
programs that over the long term are
good for for the economy can you talk a
little bit about
what are the limits of some of these
ideas in the context of inflation and
the other things that you're talking
about here
allow me to start by being a little bit
cynical please know it is against that
if it finances them
so that
you know even even very conservative
republicans in 2008 when the bottom fell
out of wall street
they went straight to the state 200
and to george w bush and they said give
us money
you know we don't care where you get it
borrow it print it the very
conservatives who were against
deficit spending uh okay cynicism aside
right
look it's it's capitalism without debt
is like christianity without hell
it doesn't work doesn't work yeah
so of course the nuanced position that
you put forward right at the end uh is
the sensible one
that if you use deficit
spending that
fueled
investment
properly correctly
sensibly that is the obviously good
thing to do
now the problem however is
that
it's now 13 years since 2008
and during those 13 years
just by saying this it concentrates the
mind
we've never had so much money
floating around
in the history of humanity
never before humanity as a whole
has been saving 30 percent of its income
not so much the americans and the and
the greeks but the chinese the world
generally right corporations look at
apple they've got 200 what some like 200
billion dollars saved i mean it's insane
that the corporation should have savings
corporations should have debts they
should be borrowing to invest when apple
has 200 billion you know of stash
you know there's a problem with
capitalism so for you know 13 years now
we've had all this money slashing around
okay
it's very
inequitably distributed but humanity
in total we have all this money in
comparison to the liquidity which is
available we've never had such low
levels of investment
so yeah
if you go to sierra leone
or to greece you know countries that are
poor and bankrupt
sierra leone and more than greece but
nevertheless you know what i mean yes i
mean you can ex
it makes perfect sense it's not pleasant
but it makes perfect sense that
investment is low
but
when you look at countries like germany
which is swimming in money swimming in
money never
in the history of germany did germany
have so much money and yet their level
of investment in things that they need
like you know 5g
renewables
things that they actually need they
still use fax machines in their
ministries
this is true
in the united states infrastructure is
dilapidated you have
huge quantities of money very low levels
of investment and that has been the case
now for 13 years now you know what this
means it means that as a species we
failed to
make use of available resources
in order to generate our capacity to
weather storms economic storms covet
climate change
so now
to start worrying about uh
debt
it is a bit too little too late in a
sense so to those who say oh but look at
the you know the the the the fed
continues to print money and the federal
government is uh running a huge deficit
yeah but you know what
you were not worried when wall street
was creating gigantic quantities of
private debt before 2008 that blew up
the world right
landed us where we are
so
let's focus on the one thing that really
matters
investment
investment
in things that human beings need
and i'm not talking about suvs i'm not
talking about you know more airports i'm
talking about renewable energy i'm
talking about artificial intelligence
that can actually help us rather than
enslave us
i'm talking about
social care i'm talking about healthcare
education the things that will make life
for humans better on this planet and
which will
allow this planet to continue to allow
us to exist on it in terms of climate
change
how do i mean we might not know the
answer to this yet but how do countries
where things are really a disaster
get out of those situations and i'll
give you so you mentioned sierra leone
you talked about greece which you have
firsthand experience with i'm from
argentina argentina now has had
uh
administration after administration
admin after administration of
disastrous different types of policy
none of which has served the vast
majority of the people and the problems
continue to get worse and worse do we
know for sure yet
in sort of the modern world that
countries can truly get out of these
disastrous situations and if so what are
the types of paths out
oh we certainly can
because you know as i said before it's
not that we don't have the money
or the resources this is this is why we
are a stupid species
because we are not in pecunius we have
the resources we have the money the
savings are there we're just not putting
it into use i mean think about it just
for one second david if i may say this
please
for the last 13 years okay in order to
stimulate the economy our central banks
have been printing money
let's not do not judge them for that
they've been printing money the question
is what did they do with this yes they
gave it to bank of america to deutsche
bank right to barclays bank and what did
these banks do they looked at little
people out there medium-sized businesses
small businesses they said no no we're
not going to trust them with the money
so they picked up the phone and they
called google apple volkswagen siemens
who already have money sitting there
doing nothing and they said to them look
we'll give it to you for free
because you know the commercial banks
got it from the central banks at
negative interest rates or next to
nothing right
so yeah apple said okay give it to me
i'm not going to invest it because if i
wanted to invest i would have invested
my own money so they take the money and
they go to the stock exchange and they
buy back their own shares right
insurance prices go up this is a
complete waste this is not creating
things that humanity needs
so yes we can get out of it
countries like the united states like
germany and so on should do what
roosevelt did in 1933
with a new deal use public finance in
order to press into the service of
things humanity needs the existing money
when it comes to countries like
argentina and greece
well we have a common fate
we have a debt that we can never repay
never never i mean even if god and her
angels descend upon the planet and
they cannot repay that debt it cannot be
repaid right so that is not cannot be
repaid has to be haircut
has to be you know it's it's what wall
street banks do all the every day they
restructure that
they cut it
so we need to have debt forgiveness
for countries that cannot repay them
because
you know
even from a selfish perspective of rich
countries
the only way they can get some money
back of what argentina or greece owes
them is if there is growth and there can
never be any growth if you have the
hedge funds you have the new york judges
uh the international monetary fund
pressurizing the government of argentina
to continue to squeeze the people of
argentina
right it's like beating up
a sick cow expect to get more milk
you're not going to get more milk the
cow will die yes it's a clever strategy
um do you believe that we are
already in a post-capitalist world
i have been known to say that yes this
is what my next book is going to be
about um i'm already putting out there
this view
uh look i'm i'm a lefty right let's
you know full disclosure yes lefty we
left this we're brought to this world
thinking
in infinite stupidity that
we came here to overthrow capitalism and
to replace it by socialism and to our
consternation we discover or i'm
discovering now that capitalism did it
itself it overthrew itself and now we
have something which is much closer to
feudalism uh and you know
my fellow leftists hate me for saying
this because
they think that my goodness you know if
if we are not here to overthrow
capitalism what's our purpose in life
and the answer is um you know to to come
clean and to accept that now capitalism
has been allowed to a very large extent
by the failures of the left over decades
and centuries
to morph into something far more
oppressive
far more exploitative and far more
dangerous for the human species
i call it techno feudalism
talk about what you mean by that techno
feudalism well
okay um
think of what happens the moment you
enter amazon.com
you exit capitalism
you enter something that resembles
a feudal thief victim
because it's a digital world belonging
to one man and his algorithm
his algorithm determines what product
you are going to see what part of the
program
product you are not going to see
if you are a seller how you can sell it
how you cannot sell it
whom you can approach amongst the
customers whom not
imagine it is a little bit like walking
outside
your building now and discovering that
the city in which you are
every single building belongs to one
person
the air belongs to that person the
pavement belongs to the person and that
person also has a capacity to turn your
head to ensure that he's you see what he
wants you to see that's not capitalism
it's not even monopoly capitalism it is
a digital feudalism a techno feudalism
and if you think that already going back
to what we were saying earlier
central bank money has replaced private
profits
so
profits have been replaced by central
bank money and markets have are being in
the process of being replaced by digital
platforms if you take profit and markets
out of capitalism you don't have
capitalism
you have something i'd call techno
feudalism
so there there are
lefties like me
who
did do not see
the overthrow of capitalism and
replacement with socialism as the goal
but rather this sort of intermediate
step
of social democracy in the northern
european
mode or model
um
is do you see that as an even plausible
path forward
um i hate to
say this but david this is dead
the water is finished it's just not
going to happen
no it can't happen why so because social
democracy worked
while capitalism was in rural health
the social democrats that you're
referring to in europe
people like billy brown the chancellor
of germany a wonderful man
all of palmer in sweden bruno kreiske in
austria yes the labour party in the 60s
and 70s in britain
what these social democratic parties and
labour parties did was to
to say okay
we're not going to change capitalism
like
you like your good self we're not going
to overthrow capitalists but we're going
to civilize
we're going to be elected and we'll play
the role of referee between workers and
capitalists
and this is what they did
they intervened in industrial disputes
they sat down the industrial
captains the captains of industry and
the trade unionists and they cut a deal
and they said okay
wages will go up by certain amount not
too much not too little
uh a part of the profits of industry is
going to be used to fund medicare or
medicaid or the health service in
britain and so on
uh
pensions and so on right sounds pretty
good yeah but it's except it's it's it's
finished
it's over
the reason is if you think about it look
at the espada social democratic party in
germany look at the social democratic
party in sweden the labour party in
britain they all moved away from this
why
because since the end of bretton woods
and the nixon shock in 1971
power has shifted away from industry to
the banking sector
value creation has been shifted away
from the world of producing real things
to the world of producing fictitious
capital
the city of london and so on the social
democrats that you admire and i used to
admire as well
once upon a time much older than you um
the social democrats uh or their
successors people who took over from
willie brown from bruno chrysler and so
on
um realized that the game
had shifted from industry from the
factory to the bank
to defend to the city of london
to the frankfurt banks to wall street
and it was much easier
if they wanted to continue to fund
medicare
pensions the welfare state to cut the
deal with the bankers the bankers had
been released from their shackles from
their new deal shackles by
uh the nixon shock and by thatcher in in
europe uh and and the deal was this
social democrats like tony blair for
instance
like the governments of francois
mitterrand in france
like
a socialist government here in greece by
pasok andres papandreou the deal they
cut with the bankers was this we will
turn a blind eye you can do whatever you
want
and you will give us a few cramps of
your table to fund the welfare state and
that would work because those crams i
mean the bankers were making so much
money during the good times before 2008
that the crimes of their table were
enough to fund the welfare state in
europe
but then in 2008 the banks went bankrupt
because all those bets that they were
allowed to take out
uh collapsed
and we ended up this you know the
weakest of citizens ended up bailing out
the bankers
at that point social democracy was
finished it was kaput why because they
didn't have those
the leaders of those parties they didn't
have either the analytical capacity or
the moral authority to say to the
bankers you know what you blew up your
banks we're going to save the banks
because we need banks but we're not
going to save you so they kept them in
power and they shifted their losses onto
the shoulders of the weakest
workers taxpayers
at that point
you have the demise of social democracy
so let me make sure giannis that i
understand correctly because this is an
important distinction
a social democracy based on industry and
workers who produce things can work but
once the economy shifts to be one
of as you've pointed out earlier techno
feudalism and banking and financial
instruments as profit-generating
elements
social democracy can't rest on top of
that
exactly
you put it beautifully
uh so if you whether you're elizabeth
warren or bernie sanders or you or me
if
the four of us were given the government
of the united states of america today
you know it would be
almost impossible
to create a functioning social democracy
without attacking the very foundations
of what i call techno feudalism what do
you what do you do with facebook or meta
as he calls it now yeah
what do you do with with wall street
how do you regulate you cannot regulate
they are 10 steps ahead of you it is
impossible to break up you know
roosevelt theodore roosevelt not
franklin roosevelt
broke up rockefeller standard oil right
okay every state's standard oil is a
separate company every town's standalone
is a separate company now you cannot do
that with a networked company like
facebook the whole point about facebook
is that your friends on facebook you
know come from everywhere you cannot
break up this company and by taking
whatsapp out of facebook you're not
accomplishing much because whatsapp is
not profit making anyway
so um the the this
digitalized financialized world we live
in
is simply not prone to the social
democratic remedies of the past we need
something far more radical and that's
why i wrote my another now because uh
the question is what
how you know
people kept asking me
if capital if you don't like what you
have now capitalism technology
call it what you may
what's the alternative mate and this was
a very difficult question so i had in
the end i felt the need to write a novel
in order to answer it
and i encourage everybody to read the
book by the way it is it's very very
interesting
one thing the last thing i want to talk
to you about i don't i don't want to
keep you too long over our time
um
cryptocurrency cryptocurrency has been
so polarizing and in particular in high
debt countries there are many
evangelists you have people feel very
strongly one way or the other my view
has been it's been around long enough
that i am going to put three to four
percent of my assets in it knowing it is
speculative and we will see what happens
i don't have a particularly
you know one side or the other view i
just think it's here and i want a little
bit of exposure to it at the personal
financial level what what do you think
about the rise of cryptocurrency
when bitcoin came out when nakamoto
published his famous paper i poured over
it i studied it for quite a few weeks
and um i found it fascinating i found it
ingenious
but um in an interview i gave to
uh wire magazine
um i said that it is a fantastic
solution to a problem we have not
discovered yet
by that what i meant that i stick to
that assessment is that it is um it's
not a currency
cryptocurrencies are not currencies and
they should they cannot be they cannot
replace dollars and uh pounds and euros
and they should not replace them it
would be catastrophic if we replaced
fiat money with cryptocurrencies that
will create a new oligarchy and it would
cause massive depressions
uh primarily because the quantity of
those currencies cannot be adjusted to
economic conditions so imagine if we had
imagine you had ethereum of bitcoin
instead of the dollar and the euro in
2020
when uh
lockdowns
reduced incomes by 15 percent
what would you you know if we didn't
have the capacity to to to print money
and throw them at the other problem
um
then the recession in 2020 would be much
much worse than what it is now the
advocates of bitcoin would say no no no
janice that's a feature not a bug by
having a limited supply
it is not uh you are not going to have
the inflation problems that printing the
additional money creates this is what
they would say yeah but that's that just
goes to show how ignorant they
are how dangerously ignorant they are
and i mean you know i hear such
such talk it's it look
think of what happened in your country
in 1929
under the herbert hoover administration
yes it's exactly what the bitcoiners say
the hoover administration the moment
wall street
went pear-shaped
and um you know
the the great recession begun which then
turned into the great depression yes
what the administration did was to
follow the lead of the bitcoiners of the
gold bugs
to say that okay now what we need to do
is tighten our belt
and certainly not print money
and let the market look after itself the
result was the great depression the
grapes of wrath
uh and you know if
that mentality
was ruling the roost in uh in in the fed
in
2020 we would have had a lot more
victims a lot more deaths of hunger
actually
if
this kind of
i call it the
the dangerous fantasy of apolitical
money that bitcoiners and the
evangelists of the various
cryptocurrencies but having said that
i do believe that blockchain
is remarkable
and smart contracts along the ethereum
line um
can be very useful when it comes to
creating decentralized systems
of um keeping records to begin with
mutually trustworthy records and also
when it comes to money
i'm a strong advocate
of central bank blockchain based digital
currencies
that i think will be the future
wow wow uh absolutely fascinating we've
been speaking with janis varufaka's
former finance minister of greece the
most recent book is another now
dispatches from an alternative present
which i can highly recommend
so great having you on i really
appreciate your time today
i enjoyed it thank you dave